دارنا المدينه المنكوبه تنوء تحت حمل ثقيل
مسؤولون صحيون يحذرون من ان الامال في
العثور على ناجينا تتضاءل لكن فرق الانقاذ
تواصل جهودها لانتشال الاحياء اينما وجدوا
كل هذه الجهود لا تزال قاصره عن الاقتراب
من طي صفحه الاستجابه الاولى للكارثه
فالوضع مفشع والفرق المختصه غير كافيه
للاحاطه بحجم الفاجعه
نطالب العالم انهم
وجوههمش احنا محتاجين الاضواء للغداره
احنا نطالب العالم انهم فنيين وتقنين اللي
تحت الركام واللي في البحر
لا يزال التحدي الاقصى في درنه انتشال جثث
الضحايا من البحر
[موسيقى]
صعبه شويه يعني التعامل معها
المتطورين بعمليه مسح على الشواطي ولو كان
في موجود حاجه تعملها
والصعوبات في التعامل مع الجثث لغياب
التقنيات الاساسيه لكن الحياه دوما ما
تكون اقوى فالهلال الاحمر الليبي اكد انه
انتشل سيدتين على قيد الحياه بعد مرور
قرابه اسبوع على الكارثه فما العوامل التي
تسهم في نجاه العالقين تحت الانقاض في
الكوارث الطبيعيه
الوصول الى المياه عامل اساسي تشير
تقديرات الى ان المده التي يمكن للانسان
ان يبقى فيها حيا دون ماء تراوح بين ثلاثه
ايام وسبعه ايام مع الاخذ بعين الاعتبار
درجات الحراره وبالتالي كميه السوائل التي
يفقدها جسم الانسان الوصول الى الهواء
اساسي ايضا وذلك يعتمد على البقعه التي
علق بها الشخص سواء تتيح ممرا للهواء او
كانت مغلقه لتفادي الاختناق عدم وجود
اصابات يساعد بدوره في استدامه الحياه
وغياب حطام ثقيل فوق جسم الشخص العالق
عامل مهم ايضا يبقى ان توفر الطعام يزيد
من فرص النجاه يمكن الاستمرار دونه اسابيع
لكن بالنسبه الى الغالبيه العظمى قد تقتصر
المهله على بضعه ايام كما يلعب عمر
الانسان دورا في البقاء على قيد الحياه
لفتره اطول وتزيد هذه المده بغياب امراض
مزمنه